[Music]
in movie netnews hmm submitted by three
fingers Steve free oh that's my cactus
oh yeah yeah little [ __ ] [ __ ] died
on me oh he's a succulent movie goer was
arrested after dumping popcorn on a
toddler who was interrupting the show
pictures a popcorn booth and in like
it's like covering the head who did it
[ __ ] I wonder if the pop was high like a
hot butter
I don't know loser is the word I say
hero but alright
it's probably what if it's your kid then
I say you better shut the [ __ ] up if we
get more popular on your head I don't
understand people that bring babies to
the [ __ ] movie is wrong when you
bring a toddler to a [ __ ] movie
theater you [ __ ] [ __ ] unless it's
like Coco yeah I would a baby not gonna
understand [ __ ] but this is toddler
Wichita toddlers love cartoons
hmm yeah they go watch that [ __ ] at home
and not disturb other people that's my
favorite toddlers bro I forgot what like
1 2 like 1 2 5
I know 5 is the cutoff but I forgot
where it sorry Oh five-year-olds a
toddler stop yeah damn other this using
when they still look like wobbly the mom
told you what it is yeah yeah yeah I
don't believe her because she doesn't
believe in science okay she hasn't been
a mom in 4,000 years I know that is true
it's been a decade all right so this
woman her name is Carrie 25 years old
from Long Island it was a girl that did
it yeah crazy
girls aren't allowed to do [ __ ] like
that that's a guy move she's a [ __ ]
yeah whoop that it was an old man
the little kids usually girls are a
little more empathic because they're
like they're trying yeah I'm a maternal
type of thing going on I'm still on this
lady's side so let's go I want to be in
the middle and pop the lady in the kid
at the same time both of them and pop
yourself for bringing the kid to the
movies no I didn't bring a market to the
movie the [ __ ] brought the
toddler and the other [ __ ]
brought the [ __ ] so pow yeah and the
[ __ ] saw justice how I hope the
baby didn't eat popcorn is unhealthy for
the baby I know the measurement baby
guidance like you know it's raining pop
maybe that's why she got arrested
because he has a popcorn allergy
deliciousness and the kids face you're
going to jail yeah so they were watching
Star Wars the last Jedi and a pair
according to the mom her name is Celia
Celia her two-year-old daughter all she
said was popcorn and that's when Carrie
apparently got so mad started yelling
and cursing at her and their little girl
and the mom that she also put up her
middle finger up to the baby's cheek it
shows like this that sounds like a David
so move
I don't think ok first of all I don't
agree with this behavior but there had
to be like little things at building up
whose behavior same Papa toddler yeah it
had to be like it was making noise and
like saying things and giggling or
whatever that it was making noise that
was like slowly irritated that's met the
mom and then the mom just heard exactly
the mom tunes it out and then the baby
was like pop court and then that was
like the final straw for the lady yeah
because I was like yeah because the
popcorn belong to the mom well maybe she
kept saying popcorn over and over and
over and the mom just heard it once yeah
yeah that sounds more plausible it's not
just like the kid was all quiet the
whole time and went popcorn
she even hit her with the hardened paper
tub that caused the little girl to have
a bruise oh my gosh from my paper tub
another saying well it's like kind of
hard in the quad of the base I mean the
but you felt tight to school right like
this I know but you felt tight the
school right I feel like my dick to
penetrate this the harder ports are this
right we reinforced yeah the same with
the base of the popcorn Oh like that
that's one of the layered cardboard yeah
and then the kids had their Scout their
school isn't fully develops it's still
very soft yeah why would you hurt the
kid hurt him mom that's what I'm saying
if you're pissed
just deal with the mom cuz she's the one
that brought the annoying kid yeah and
he's not controlling the kids you like
be quieter cuz how can you [ __ ] flip
flip off the kid what does what the hell
the kid doesn't know that's like if
someone got that close to my kid without
buck and break their [ __ ] little
finger off and just sawed it off and
then just say you can't have it back if
you're gonna be a psycho biological
psycho at least and I think like the
most upsetting part of the story is the
fact that it wasn't it was I thought it
was her popcorn how do you it's Michael
yeah I have to [ __ ] but I bought that
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
you take your popcorn thought over Mike
yeah she had to reach over grab the
popcorn and then put it on the kid
that's what I'm saying yeah she got up a
violent enough that it bruised the kid's
head that's kind of funny though that me
she threw it that she went and I don't
like going to the movies on the day that
it opens and when it's super busy that's
why I always go to Arclight because
parents are totally yeah exactly and
that's why you have loud kids
Arclight is too it's two dollars more
and you go to Arclight and on top of
that they have people that will kick
your [ __ ] ass out if you talk that's
true yeah they take the movie BMC has
the lazy boy chairs though yeah but
those things are more expensive too and
then on top of that they're not gonna go
there that's a good point go to lazy boy
with a lot of them were
like the one in Sacramento that I think
I saw as a kid all lazy a lazy boy
change your clothes to the Burbank wine
the one by the mall like that one is
dope because it's like small like a
small feeder but it has the good
theaters with the lazy boys in them yeah
so this is Carrie so she was at the
theater
her dad named Charles this dude [ __ ]
old Seinfeld
oh she's 25 25 according to a theater
worker they said that Carrie got her bad
manners from old dad her dad because he
is a mega trouble starter I talked about
the theater these their regulars yeah
apparently that their regulars and so he
thought you'd found before you've gotten
in trouble before by starting some [ __ ]
because like someone sat in his seat or
something and then they said oh they
need to get their asses beat and they'll
get checked real quick so that's all
according to the movie theater worker
and the mom right but then Kari has her
own friends and then they're saying
harry has friends yeah and then she like
that friend is saying that Kerry would
never hurt a child she doesn't have a
violent bone in her body there's no way
she would have done this she looks like
she eats children for breakfast that's
what I'm saying anybody with the faith
like this and everything is scrunched in
the middle she's for sure it's funny
because I only picture her cooking [ __ ]
in a cauldron yeah yeah what can [ __ ]
salamander nice she's the one [ __ ]
offering that apple an apple ooh also
how small is this town that that's like
oh the oh the buck Cielo family they
come in here all the time the dad is
really mean you're like the theater
workers they all know so this is Marley
she's alone I got oh how can you throw
pop back she's a mom
which this isn't mom by the way she said
that that Kari was lying because Kari
was saying that the kid was being so
disruptive I did just like push her to
her limits but then the mom was like no
one else complained about my daughter
like how is it possible that people
don't really complain about they use the
most innocent pictures so I believe the
me every child picture is pretty [ __ ]
innocent no I'm talking about the mom
cuz you don't have her like dressing
like a hoochie at the club
no running mascara then you'll be like
oh [ __ ] she has an innocent smile but
the other one she looks like the street
up with like a mug shot of it good skin
yeah but how can you how can your face
be so square the square is face I've
ever seen in my life
it reminds me of like a me character in
the the weed you know I think that we
use them like holy [ __ ] there has crazy
volume that's what I was just gonna say
girl oh [ __ ] but she looks like she
could be cute if she smiled and Worstell
makeup that's what I'm saying they
picked the wrong picture they gave the
guilty picture oh now it she looks like
an evil Jessie J that's what she looks
fine cuz she's got good cheekbones cuz
if heard her have her dad was like
smiling and it was Christmas and they
had like tacky Christmas sweaters on and
they're like holding the Chihuahua
that's a totally different picture than
those mug shots
wait wait the Huq of the [ __ ] could you
throw popcorn at a baby like that I've
never been on a plane where that kid is
kicking the [ __ ] oh my gosh yeah no I
was in the chair and then the getting
kick like crazy nozzle I hopefully this
thing [ __ ] stops on his own they just
kept going and it got to the point well
I'm pretty tired I kind of want to take
a nap so I turn around and I saw the
parents and I was like hey excuse me
your kid is taking my charity thing
could ask them to stop and in the only
cop so sorry
and then so now I'm at alright cool I'm
just chilling and then I just I feel
like that and I hear the parallel now
it's a fight between the parent and the
kid and that became so entertaining now
I might add also it was delicious
because you can feel the kid like uses
resist just want stay kick because
there's like there's a point where on my
chair you know when you tap you can feel
the tap the vibration of a tap I felt
this look I think just put his foot on
there and like looking at his pair and
his mom was like if I saw my kid just do
that and I'm just looking directly in
their eyes they just go like this just
looking at them and they tap it I'm
immediately gonna punch you in your
chest what do you guys know your kids
valid but what are you doing like
there's 20 other people I'll still punch
him in the chest
my mom would flick my cheek you know
what I would do you know how to do this
is what I'll do I'll ask for some
peanuts I'll spill the peanuts on their
chest you have something on your chest
boom that blood just ketchup using is
the kind of guy who talks like this and
then he's a daddy and he's like the
nicest dad he's like cuz my kids are
gonna be angels I thought my uncle was
you so mean to us he's like nope you're
gone you so mean who's the mean uncle
then he had a kid he says his kid do
whatever he wants the reason why I don't
want to let my kid do whatever they want
because I hate it when they disturb
other people yeah you mean you disturb
me as much as you want that's fine but
everybody else they're not having kids
if they don't have kids they don't want
do with your [ __ ] [ __ ] you gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]